ja das ist die Pressekonferenz auf die
wir eigentlich gewartet haben und dort
wollte Vladimir Putin der russische
Präsident eigentlich über die
militärischen Ziele im nächsten Jahr
berichten und wie sie liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer das auch
gerade eben miterleben konnten gab es
jetzt zu einer Art Marketing Film für
die russischen staatlichen gaskonzernen
Gazprom und darüber möchte ich mal mit
Professor Andreas heinemann-grüder
sprechen der ist Politikwissenschaftler
und konfliktforscher in Bonn und einen
Kenner des
Osteuropas ähm was für eine Message soll
von diesen Bildern ausgehen für das
Publikum in Russland ja in erster Linie
aber vielleicht auch weltweit
die Botschaft ist die Sanktionen wirken
nicht wir bauen hier gleichzeitig die
Verbindung über die Pipeline Kraft
sibiens nach China aus wir expandieren
letztlich die Bevölkerung muss nicht
beunruhigt sein weil die Einnahmen
weiter sprudeln und man kann natürlich
auch sagen Gazprom hat durchaus
Riesengewinne in diesem Jahr eingefahren
von 41 Milliarden Euro gleichzeitig ist
aber die Produktion um ungefähr 20%
gesunken und das kann auch nicht durch
China vollkommen kompensiert werden aber
wir hatten jetzt die Meldung
vor 24 Stunden etwa das ist ein Anschlag
auf die Yamaha Pipeline gegeben hat die
ja ähm nach Europa führt über die
Ukraine und da soll jetzt sozusagen die
gegen Botschafter vermeldet werden wir
brauchen ja eigentlich auch die
Pipelines North Stream 1 und 2 durch die
Ostsee und auch die dabei bleibt dann
nicht weil wir das alles mit China wett
machen können wir können ja auch gerade
eben im Bild und noch im o-turnen kurz
sehen den gazprom-chef im Millers ja ein
enger Vertrauter von Wladimir Putin soll
das auch noch mal zeigen dass die
Oligarchen und das auch die
Führungskräfte in der Wirtschaft eng an
der Seite des Präsidenten stehen ist das
auch noch mal eine Message oder konnte
man da auch was anderes aus den Bildern
noch interpretieren
letztlich ein staatskonzernen insofern
ist die Botschaft jetzt bei der der
sozusagen Reklame für Gastronom weniger
das jetzt die Oligarchen dahinter Putin
stehen sondern eher angesichts der
insgesamt ja depressiven Stimmung in der
Wirtschaft also man hat extrem hohe
Zinsen über zehn Prozent im Vergleich
zum letzten Jahr man hat vier Prozent
Minus Wachstum also Rezessionen in
Russland und vor dem Hintergrund sondern
eigentlich diese Botschaft vermittelt
werden
kein Defätismus sondern
optimismus ist angesagt und wer
expandieren wie wichtig ist überhaupt
die Rohstoff Ausbeute in Russland noch
jetzt beispielsweise mit diesem neuen
Gasfeld wo ja auch zig neue Gasquellen
gleichzeitig mit erschlossen werden ist
das eigentlich alles noch exportierbar
nachdem ja Deutschland und die
Europäische Union z.B seit Anfang
nächsten Jahres dann kein Öl mehr
abnehmen wird aus oder nur noch ein sehr
begrenzten Maße Gas fließt ja auch nur
noch im Bruchteil nach Westeuropa
brauchte Russland überhaupt diese
Rohstoffvorkommen noch kann man die noch
vermarkten
also von denen Gasvorkommen die jetzt
eigentlich nach Europa transportiert
oder exportiert werden sollten wird
schon sehr viel abgefackelt weil man das
eben gar nicht mehr in die Leitungen
reinpumpen kann also da große
Umweltverschmutzung weil der Druck da
sozusagen auch abgebaut werden muss
durch durch abfackeln
natürlich kommt mit diesem Krieg
letztlich dieser dieses ganze
pedrostaatsmodell also
Einkünfte werden über Öl und Gas
generiert für den russischen Staat das
kommt zu einem Ende ich glaube nicht
dass sie das bis heute gänzlich
anerkennen dass dieses Wirtschaftsmodell
auf dem Putin Herrschaft Berufe auch mit
den Sanktionen und mit den
eingeschränkten Exportmöglichkeiten nach
Europa dass das letztlich ein Ende
gekommen ist und wie gesagt selbst wenn
ich nach China und Indien mehr
exportiert wird möglicherweise auch nach
an in andere
südostasiatische Staaten kann das den
europäischen Markt nicht kompensieren
das Modell wir warten ja auch noch auf
eine Erklärung von Vladimir Putin
bezüglich der militärischen Ziele in
2023 da soll es ja nach Aussage seines
Regierungssprechers pescofer ein Treffen
mit hochrangigen Militärs geben wir
hatten gedacht dass es möglicherweise
jetzt in diesen Minuten schon sozusagen
diese Erklärung geben wird eine
substanzielle Erklärung soll das sein
eine wichtige Erklärung so Pesto auf
Dimitri pescock was können wir da
erwarten werden wir da noch mal
irgendwelche großen Veränderungen
erwarten können
ich gehe nicht davon aus dass eine
Winteroffensive die von manchen
sozusagen befürchtet oder
für Möglichkeiten wird tatsächlich
anderen gekündigt wird sozusagen vor dem
Publikum sondern da wird man den
Überraschungseffekt noch für sich zu
nutzen suchen gleichzeitig denke ich
dass die Bevölkerung die Wirtschaft die
Verwaltung die Politik in den Regionen
aber auch das Militär vorbereitet werden
müssen für einen langen Krieg das heißt
auch für die Umstellung auf eine
Kriegswirtschaft dann werden
Ankündigungen gemacht dahingehend wieder
in die Kriegs Beteiligten also die
Soldaten auf materiell versorgt werden
es wird irgendwie Anreize geben für
freiwillige damit man bei der
Mobilisierung noch mehr Leute bekommt es
wird gleichzeitig auch noch deutlich
wieder Drohungen geben
in Richtung derjenigen die gegen den
Krieg protestieren oder sich ihren
vaterländischen Pflichten durch
Flucht ins Ausland entziehen also ich
gehe davon aus dass es hier vor
Weihnachten vor dem Jahreswechsel eine
Vorbereitung sozusagen auf einen eine
längere Kriegsphase gibt wobei ich nicht
davon ausgehe dass man den Kriegsziele
wirklich bei so einer öffentlichen
Veranstaltung
öffentlich speziellifiziert werden wir
haben jetzt von dieser anderen
Veranstaltung möglicherweise hier ein
paar Bilder vorliegen die uns von der
Nachrichtenagentur Reuters zur Verfügung
gestellt werden und wir erwarten ja dort
auch ein längeres Statement von Vladimir
Putin wir hatten gerade eben schon ein
bisschen mal darüber spekuliert mehr ist
es ja im Moment nicht was wir da
eigentlich erwarten können aber im
Prinzip ist es ja momentan einfacher zu
sagen was wir nicht erwarten können
Präsident selensky der Präsident der
Ukraine er ist ja auf dem Weg in die USA
wird dort Joe Biden treffen wird dort
also den US-Präsidenten er wird dort
noch mal offiziell bestätigt bekommen
dass die Ukraine Patriots Systeme
bekommt und er wird auch wohl vor dem
Kongress oder dem Repräsentantenhaus
eine Rede halten das hat er ja schon
vielen anderen Ländern gemacht spielte
ein bisschen an dem heutigen Tag wo alle
eigentlich nach Moskau auf die große
Ankündigung von Vladimir Putin warten
steht da ein bisschen die Show
ich glaube das sind so zwei
parallelchshows ich meine die
konkurrieren ja um die Aufmerksamkeit
der Weltöffentlichkeit
sehr häufig
natürlich ist das auch eine Reaktion
selenskys und ein Signal auch der USA
dass sie ihn eingeladen haben auf das
was hier von russischer Seite an
Konflikt Eskalation zu erwarten ist
insofern
symbolisch ist das hochbedeutsam dass
jetzt in dieser Phase diese Reise von
selensky erstmals nach Kriegsausbruch in
die USA stattfindet und damit vielleicht
auch die Reihen in den USA wieder etwas
geschlossener sind die zumindest in den
letzten Wochen sowohl bei den Demokraten
aber auch bei dem Militärs im Pentagon
gewisse Risse gezeigt haben
Professor Heinemann grüner sie sind ja
auch konfliktforscher jetzt würde ich
gerne mal von Ihnen wissen wie ist denn
dieser Konflikt Russlands Angriffskrieg
in der Ukraine die Vernichtung von
Milliarden von Wirtschaftskraft in der
Ukraine der Tod von vielen tausenden
vielleicht sogar 100.000 Menschen in der
Ukraine wie kann man so ein Konflikt
denn überhaupt beenden wenn beide Seiten
sich dermaßen sozusagen im Inland
festgelegt hat Präsident sie insgesamt
Befreiung aller Gebiete inklusive der
Krim und Russland hat ja bereits einige
ukrainische Gebiete annektiert was
natürlich in von keinem Land oder nur
von ganz ganz wenigen Ländern anerkannt
wurde wie kann man so ein Konflikt
überhaupt beenden
ich glaube es sind zwei Dinge
entscheidend das eine die Rolle von
äußeren Mächten die häufig auch
Konflikte beendet haben
ich meine der Zweite Weltkrieg ist auch
durch äußere Mächte beendet worden aber
viele andere auch
es wird nicht zu einer Art von
diktatfrieden kommen aber das
Großmächte und ich wurde dazu auch China
zählen und natürlich auch die USA
einerseits Garantien für den Frieden
aussprechen und sagen so könnte der
Zustand nach dem Krieg aussehen und wir
garantieren diesen Frieden dann auch mit
eigenen Kräften möglicherweise auch mit
mit einem Mandat entweder das
UN-Sicherheitsrates oder von
irgendwelchen
regionalorganisationen die sich daran
beteiligen also das eine ist sein der
Druck der für den Großmächten ausgeht
und das zweite ist dass die
Konfliktparteien erkennen wir können
keine Gewinne mehr auf dem Schlachtfeld
machen und dass sie den Frieden
letztlich der eigenen Bevölkerung
verkaufen müssen und ich glaube das ist
mit eins der größten Probleme silensky
kann eigentlich kaum etwas anderes
seiner eigenen Bevölkerung verkaufen als
die Rückgabe der russischen okkupierten
Territorien und Putin hat sich auch
rhetorisch so weit vorgewagt dass er
kaum etwas anderes als die voller
Anerkennung der annektierten Gebiete
seinem eigenen Publikum verkaufen können
also es wird letztlich ein großes
politisches Problem
weil
es kann sein dass sie Gefangene ihrer
eigenen Rhetorik sind und mit einem
Frieden stürzen weil sie nicht verkaufen
können wir haben gerade Informationen
bekommen ich spreche jetzt auch noch mal
das Bild an was die Zuschauerinnen und
Zuschauer dort sehen können aus Moskau
dort haben sich vor Ort bereits man kann
das nur schätzen wahrscheinlich mehrere
hundert hochrangige Militärs versammelt
laut Agentur berichten sollen noch
einige tausend weitere
Entscheidungsträger mit
zugeschaltet werden und warten auf die
Ankündigung von Präsident Wladimir Putin
und oder seinem Verteidigungsminister
Scholl GU die wollen über die
militärischen Ziele 2023 noch mal
berichten also wir werden da wie gesagt
wir gehen wir davon aus dass das in
wenigen Minuten dann hier live bei
Phoenix zu sehen sein wird
Herr Professor Heinemann Günther ich
würde sie ein grüner ich würde sie gerne
noch mal fragen sie hatten es gerade
eben schon mal angedeutet eigentlich
haben sich beide Staats- und
Regierungschefs in eine Ecke manövriert
wo sie kaum noch herauskommen weil die
mir Putin und auch der ukrainische
Präsident selenski bedeutet das im
Umkehrschluss aus ihrer Sicht eigentlich
brauchen wir in beiden Ländern eine neue
Führung und dann können dauerhaften
Frieden erreichen
in der in Russland muss man sich in der
Tat Fragen ist ein Friedensschluss mit
Putin noch möglich
weil er wenn er sich auf die Bedingungen
eines
akzeptablens Friedens
einlässt ihr letztlich ja eingestehen
muss dass er seine deklarierten
Kriegsziele nicht erreicht hat ich würde
von daher davon ausgehen dass vielleicht
ein Waffenstillstand mit Putin noch
möglich ist aber eine dauerhafte
Friedenslösung halte ich unter Putin für
sehr unwahrscheinlich also insofern mit
Putin vielleicht bestenfalls ein
einfrierendes Konfliktes
silenski hat natürlich sehr starke
Unterstützung in der Bevölkerung und
dort werden sich alle Fragen warum haben
wir so viel Leid auf uns genommen wenn
wir letztlich uns hier auf einen faulen
Frieden einlassen müssen dafür sind ja
nicht unsere Soldaten gestorben also im
russischen Falle würde ich eher sagen
sagen ja an Frieden wird das Ende von
Putin einleiten im Falle von silensky
würde ich das jetzt noch nicht sehen
wobei auch da in der Ukraine ist die
Frage selbst wenn man diese Gebiete
zurückerobert man muss letztlich auch
diese Bevölkerung integrieren die da
jahrelang unter russischer Propaganda
gelebt hat in russische Schulen sind die
Kinder gegangen viele von denen haben
russische Pässe angenommen also die
ganze Frage dann hat der nationalen
Einheit stellt sich für die Ukraine
selbst in dem Falle wo sie die Gebiete
rückerobern auch wieder vollkommen neu
man kann hier nicht alle in chinesische
Umerziehungslager schicken die da seit
mehr als acht Jahren jetzt unter
russischer Herrschaft gelebt haben und
russische Pässe haben und in Rubel als
Zahlungsmittel benutzen und so weiter
eine ganz spannende Frage ist ja auch
das Verhältnis zu Belarus ich würde
gleich gerne mit Ihnen Herr Professor
Heinemann Brüder darüber noch mal weiter
reden aber vielleicht noch mal ein ganz
kurzer ein Spielfilme zu mir putin war
ja vor zwei Tagen beim Nachbarland Bäder
Russe beim Präsidenten Lukaschenko dort
zu Besuch es geht ja nach wie vor darum
wird sich Lukaschenko wird sich Peter
Russ am Krieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine beteiligen und es geht natürlich
auch nach wie vor um die Stimmung in
Moskau
der Winter in moskauki park er könnte so
schön sein wäre da nicht Russlands
sogenannte spezialoperation weil die
nicht so läuft wie geplant wird in der
russischen Führung offenbar fleißig
getötet was hat dieser Mann als nächstes
vor
Wladimir Putin ist zurzeit auffallend
beschäftigt am Samstag unter Militärs
Putin studiert Dokumente vom
Pressedienst extra unkenntlich gemacht
den ganzen Tag habe Putin hier verbracht
so die offizielle Meldung
ich würde gerne Ihre Vorschläge hören
was wir in nächster Zeit und
mittelfristig tun werden
Putin fliegt nach Minsk Treffen mit
Belarus macht Tabaluga schenko dem
engsten Verbündeten den Putin noch hat
Lukaschenko witzelt über das Image der
beiden in der Welt
wir sind ja beide Aggressoren die
schädlichsten und toxischsten Menschen
auf unserem Planeten wir streiten nur
darum wer schlimmer ist Wladimir
vladimirovic sagt ich sei es und ich
fange an zu denken er ist schlimmer wir
haben dann entschieden dass wir beide
gleich schlimm sind
Putin und Luca schenkko vereinbaren mehr
militärische Kooperation doch in den
Krieg gegen die Ukraine will Lukaschenko
sich mit eigenen Soldaten noch immer
nicht reinziehen lassen aber wie lange
hält der putins-druck Stand
schon im Februar hatte Russland von
Belarus aus Truppen zur Eroberung Kiews
losgeschickt jetzt spekulieren
Beobachter über einen möglichen neuen
Versuch
Russlands Verteidigungsministerium
verbreitet Bilder die Übungen russischer
Truppen in Belarus zeigen sollen und
Peter russische Aktivisten berichten
russische Truppen sein Richtung
ukrainische Grenze verlegt worden
Putin verleim Kreml Orden an die
Statthalter der annektierten
ukrainischen Regionen und sagt
überraschend deutlich dass Russland dort
unter Druck stehe in einem Video an
kämpfende Soldaten und Sicherheitskräfte
und Person ist äußerst schwierig aber
auf ihren Schutz verlassen sich die dort
lebenden Menschen es sind Bürger
Russland
an einer großen Sitzung des
Verteidigungsministeriums teilnehmen
15.000 Mitglieder der Streitkräfte
sollen per Video schalte zuhören es geht
um die militärischen Ziele im nächsten
Jahr und womöglich auch um eine
russische Winteroffensive in der Ukraine
ja und diese Veranstaltung die gerade
eben in den Beitrag angekündigt worden
ist soll jetzt in diesen Minuten
stattfinden man konnte es ganz kurz eben
schon auf den Bildern sehen dass die
Anwesenden Militärs die da alle
natürlich an den Uniformen gut zu
erkennen sind dass die schon mal
aufgestanden sind und wenn es pünktlich
losgeht dann in wenigen ein zwei Minuten
dann wird Vladimir Putin dort in den
Raum treten und auch wohl das sagt
zumindest der auch die
Nachrichtenagentur Reuter sein
verteilungsminister Scheu gut die beiden
Verben dort
auf jeden Fall anwesend sein so sagen es
wie gesagt er mit einer Vorbehalt die
Agenturmeldungen und die keynot also
sozusagen die Eröffnungsrede soll der
Verteidigungsminister halten da wäre
noch mal eine Frage an Professor Andreas
Heinemann Gründer
wie stark ist die Stellung des Militärs
überhaupt noch in Russland und vor allen
Dingen die das Verteidigungsministers
ich habe ihn vor zwei Tagen auf Bildern
gesehen aus Weißrussland er humpelte er
trug einen Arm verdeckt er macht einen
deutlich angeschlagenen Eindruck und
auch die ganzen Erfolge und vor allem
die Misserfolge werden ihm ja anzulassen
sein wie lange ist der überhaupt noch zu
halten was schätzen Sie da
gut die nimmt ihn in die Verantwortung
indem er ihn jetzt auf vorschiebt mit
dieser Rede und Putin hat ja seine
Jahrespressekonferenz und auch dieses
jährlich stattfindende
Spektakel da Fragen der Bevölkerung an
Putin das hat er ja beides abgesagt also
insofern wird jetzt ein Teil der
Verantwortung auch auf Scheu gut den
Verteidigungsminister abgeschoben Putin
kann ihn damit auch öffentlich eher
unter Druck setzen und in die Pflicht
nehmen und sich selber aber auch von
Misserfolgen möglicherweise
distanzieren also ich denke das ist
jetzt nicht das Bemühen den Scheu gut
schon abzusetzen weil das natürlich
sowohl für das heimische als auch für
das internationale Publikum
Eingeständnis dessen wäre dass sein
bisheriger Verteidigungsminister nur
mich aber Folge eingefahren hat und
nicht nur Schwierigkeiten das Ziel ist
jetzt deutlich zu machen wir erkennen
die Schwierigkeiten an aber was ist die
Strategie
in den nächsten Monaten
aus dieser sozusagen Sackgasse wieder
herauszukommen und da da wird der Scheu
go liefern müssen sowohl beim Thema
Rüstungs also
Nachschub bei der Rüstung bei den Waffen
bei der Munition bei technologischen
Erneuerungen aber auch Mobilisierung
Unterstützung für die Soldaten bei den
Themen wird er was sagen müssen da sind
wir genau bei dem Thema was mich jetzt
auch noch mal interessieren würde sie
sprachen noch mal an technische
Neuerungen in der Armee sie sprachen das
Thema an da wird der
Verteidigungsminister liefern müssen
kann er das überhaupt der es gab einen
viel beachteten Artikel am letzten
Freitag der wurde ja auch in Deutschland
haben Wochenende denn viel diskutiert
der Kolleginnen und Kollegen der New
York Times und in diesem Artikel wurde
ja noch mal davon gesprochen das größte
Teile oder größere Teile muss man
vielleicht vorsichtiger formulieren
größerer Teile der Armee
potenschke Dörfer sozusagen nur sein und
jetzt sehen wir auch würde jetzt die
Bilder hier gerne anspreche die Bilder
von Vladimir Putin er wird jetzt dort
tritt dort jetzt ein in den Saal und
schon ist der Verteidigungsminister und
girassimov meine ich den
Oberbefehlshaber der Streitkräfte habe
ich da erkannt also wir hören jetzt was
er zu sagen hat
verehrte Damen und Herren wir treffen
uns hier beim alljährlichen Treffen des
Verteidigungsministeriums in einer sehr
verantwortungsvollen Zeit die
militärische sonderparation geht weiter
und heute haben wir die Erfahrung und
bei den truppenhandlungen werden wir die
Schlüsselbereiche der Entwicklung der
Armee besprechen zunächst einmal möchte
ich ganz aufrichtig Danke sagen an
unsere Offiziere und Soldaten die jetzt
an den Frontlinien kämpfen oder in den
Zentren der Vorbereitung des Personals
sie alle
erfüllen ihre Pflicht sie riskieren ihr
Leben sie sollen keine Mühen und wenn
sie müssen dann
riskieren sie ihr eigenes Leben und
heute müssen wir natürlich auch an alle
unsere Kampfes Brüder denken die ihr
Leben gelassen haben für die Heimat
vielen Dank
verehrte Teilnehmer des Kollegiums es
ist gut bekannt dass heute gegen
Russland ganz aktiv das militärische
Potenzial genutzt wird und auch die
Möglichkeit fast alle aller wichtigen
naturländer nichtsdestotrotz
das ist so dass unsere Offiziere
Soldaten tapfer für Russland kämpfen
Schritt für Schritt lösen Sie die
Gestalten Aufgaben diese Aufgaben werden
zweifelsfrei erfüllt werden
auf allen Gebieten der Russischen
Föderation darunter auch in den neuen
Gebieten
wir werden für
das sichere Leben aller unserer Bürger
sorgen die Truppen und die Kampfes
Mittel unserer Truppen wachsen ständig
jeden Tag und dieser Prozess wird
natürlich auch weitergehen und wird
ansteigen ich möchte noch einmal Danke
sagen an alle diejenigen die heute
Dienst tun und ihre Pflicht erfüllen im
Kampf weil ich danke denjenigen den
Panzern Arbeiten in der alterenie
in der Kommunikation in der Flughafen
speziell Spezialisten bei der Versorgung
der russischen Garde und auch anderer
Truppen dafür wie sie kämpfen sie
kämpfen wie ich weiß und ich scheue den
Vergleich nicht
das sind keine hohen Worte sie sind
wahrhaftig Helden des Kriege zum
Beispiel 1812 auch wie im ersten oder im
Zweiten Weltkrieg ganz besondere Worte
des an die kriegsmediziner die ganz oft
ihr eigenes Leben riskieren und unsere
Kämpfer retten die militärischen und
auch die zivilen
Bauingenieure die die lebenswichtige
Infrastruktur aufrechterhalten in den
Kampfgebieten für die Hilfe der
Wiederaufbaus auf den befreiten Gebieten
und dennoch ist es so dass die
Kampfhandlungen auch die Fragen
offengelegt haben über die wir ganz
besonders arbeiten müssen bearbeiten
müssen wir haben das schon mehrmals
angesprochen die Kommunikation
automatisierte
Systeme der Truppen die Taktik des
Kampfes
und so weiter das ist die Kampf
Erfahrung die wir nutzen müssen und
werden bei unserem weiteren Vorgehen und
dem Aufbau der Entwicklung der Truppen
und das Militärs heute besteht unsere
Aufgabe darin hier notwendige Maßnahmen
umzusetzen für die Erneuerung und die
Optimierung
darauf möchte ich Ihre besondere
Aufmerksamkeit lenken die gesamte
Information
der über die nato-kräfte der Mittel die
eingesetzt werden im Laufe der
militärischen sonderoperation
sind uns sehr gut bekannt das alles
liegt Ihnen vor und das alles muss ganz
gründlich analysiert werden genutzt
werden für den Aufbau unserer wie ich
bereits sagte Truppen unsere Armee um
unsere Kampfmöglichkeiten unserer
Truppen zu steigern und auch unsere
heimischen Sicherheitskräfte ein riesige
Kampferfahrung haben wir nun in unseren
Truppen im Laufe dieser militärischen
sonderoperation das
Verteidigungsministerium in der
Generalstab sie müssen diese Erfahrung
gründlich analysieren schnell das
islamisieren und auch in
vorbereitungsprogramme einfließen zu
lassen für die Vorbereitung der Truppen
und für Technik Lieferungen bald die
Erfahrung bei der militärischen
sonderbaration die wir auch schon in
Syrien hatten bei unseren Truppen muss
die Grundlage sein für eine
ernstzunehmende Optimierung der Übungen
wir müssen bei der Vorbereitung bei den
Übungen bei den Trainings auf allen
Ebenen das einfließen lassen bei den
Offizieren bei den Feldwebeln
sie müssen prioritär auf neue Posten
versetzt werden
die erste Personalreserve in den
Hochschulen auch bei den
Militärakademien und das Generalstabs
das muss alles genutzt werden zweitens
ich lenke ihre Aufmerksamkeit das
Verteidigungsministeriums andere
Behörden darauf dass wir hier ganz eng
zusammenarbeiten müssen im Rahmen
von speziell dafür geschaffenen
Strukturen im Koordinationsrat darunter
auch mit den Führungskräften der Region
und in Vertretern der Militärindustrie
ich erwarte von Ihnen auch dass unsere
Konstrukteure Ingenieure weiterhin die
Praxis und die Best Practices einsetzen
ich danke dafür sie nehmen regelmäßig an
wichtigen Treffen teil und korrigieren
die Technik optimieren Sie und ich hoffe
dass diese Praxis auch weitergehen wird
dass sie die Taktik der Kampfmittel und
das Materials der Technik wie ich
bereits sagte schon optimieren werden
und vorhanden treiben werden insgesamt
muss man hier mit den zuständigen
Ministerien Behörden zusammenarbeiten
wir sehen dass die Arbeit hervorragend
ist die Ingenieure die Techniker die
Wissenschaftler sehen das alles und
diese ganze Maschinerie funktioniert ich
sagte ja schon wie optimieren das und
werden das auch weiterhin optimieren ich
meinte unsere Technik und darunter fällt
auch dieser Prozess den ich angesprochen
habe dann gibt es noch Team
militärindustriekommission hier geht es
um die Verteidigungsindustrie für die
Wissenschaft für die Truppen für die
Verteidigung für alle lebenswichtigen
Aufgaben und Fragen
auch bei Material bei der Versorgung der
Truppen da meine ich auch die Technik
und die Kampfmittel und so weiter
drittens wir werden auch weiterhin
die Kampfbereitschaft unterstützen und
auch im Nuklearbereich aufrechterhalten
das ist die wichtigste Garantie der
Aufrechterhaltung unserer Souveränität
und der territorialen Integrität der
strategischen Parität insgesamt der
kraftballons in der Welt das Niveau der
Bewaffnung auch immer thomartenbereich
ist schon über 91% weiterhin werden wir
die Truppen umstrukturieren wir haben
einen modernen nuklearen Bereich mit
ultra Schall Avantgarde Zukunft werden
wir zum nächsten Mal interkontinentale
ballistische raketen-format liefern wir
wissen da gibt es ein paar Bewegungen um
das verändert nicht unsere Pläne auch im
rechtlichen Bereich die Truppen bekommen
auch
raketenkomplexe Jahres
wir werden weiterhin die einzigartigen
Technologien und
ultraschallkomplexe raketenkomplexe
weiter treiben Anfang Januar des
nächsten Jahres
werden wir die Fregatte in Betrieb
nehmen gorschkov mit den modernsten mit
den einzigartigen
hyper-ultraschallsystemen in der Marine
zerkopf und das kennt in der Welt kann
es seinesgleichen
wir werden mit den modernsten Waffen
kämpfen ich wiederhole mich alle
gesetzten Pläne werden erfüllt werden
weiter es ist wichtig die
Kampfmöglichkeiten auch in der Luft zu
erhöhen auch die Kampfjets bei ihrer
Arbeit mit den modernen Luftabwehrsystem
die aktuelle Aufgabe ist es die
drohnenflüge zu optimieren zu
perfektionieren und auch ihre
Schlagfertigkeit zu erhöhen und auch
ihre Einsatz zu verbessern die Erfahrung
der sonderoperation zeigt dass die
Nutzung der Drohnen fast überall
stattfindet und so ein Arsenal an
Mitteln muss auch in den Truppen in
allen Bataillon Kompanien vorhanden sein
das Ziel muss so schnell wie möglich
festgelegt werden und die Information
über Schläge muss in Realtime erfolgen
die Drohnen müssen
verbunden sein und integriert sein in
ein einheitliches Netz erkundungsnetz
wir brauchen geschützte
Kommunikationsziele mit den Kommandeuren
und in näherer Zukunft ist es möglich
Informationen zu bekommen über die
Drohnen und das muss jeder Kämpfer haben
das muss unser erklärtes Ziel sein
technisch kann man das umsetzen und zwar
schon sehr bald fast jetzt schon und ich
bitte Sie daran zu denken wenn sie diese
ganze ausrüstungs- und taktische
Ausrüstungsmöglichkeiten des Personals
überdenken
wir wissen dass im Kampf fällt es keine
Einzelheiten geben kann deswegen muss
man ganz besonders darauf achten ich
weiß dass das Ministerium sich damit
beschäftigt
nichtsdestotrotz möchte ich das noch
einmal hervorheben auch die
medizinischen Apotheken Nahrung
Lebensmittel Schutzausrüstung
Schutzwesten das alles muss das
modernste Niveau haben
notwendig ist es auch Nachtsichtgeräte
zu haben auch qualitativ hochwertig mit
Gewehren der neuen Generation ich werde
hier nicht alles aufzählen ich sage nur
das wichtigste alles was notwendig ist
für die Kämpfer muss modern sein bequem
und zuverlässig die Versorgung muss aus
grundlegend auf den Bedarfen erfolgen
wenn irgendwelche Normen veraltet sind
müssen sie verändert werden und zwar
schnell ich möchte Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
darauf lenken aller Kommandeure des
generalstaats des Verteidigungsministers
ich möchte sagen wir haben überhaupt
keine Einschränkungen bei der
Finanzierung das Land die Regierung wir
geben alles was die Armee verlangt alles
ich hoffe dass die Antwort auch
dementsprechend formuliert wird und
dementsprechend wir auch entsprechende
zu sehen ich komme zurück zu den Drohnen
wir haben eine gute Erfahrung der Arbeit
mit einzigartigen Unterwasser Drohnen
Systemen ich weiß dass die Industrie
auch über alle Möglichkeiten verfügt zur
Schaffung einer breiten eines breiten
Portfolios auch über Boden Drohnen die
besten
sie haben hochtaktische
Eigenschaften darunter auch künstlicher
Intelligenz wir müssen insgesamt auch
die Fragen der Erweiterung des Arsenals
der modernen schlagsysteme ausarbeiten
fünftens wir müssen das System der
Verwaltung der Kommunikation verbessern
um wir die Steuerung der Truppen in
allen Bedingungen sicherstellen können
dafür müssen wir ganz aktiv den
künstlichen Intellekt nutzen auf einen
Entscheidungsebenen Video Erfahrung
gezeigt hat auch in den letzten Monaten
ist das effizienteste System das sehr
schnell wirkt und fast automatisch
zeigte bestimmte Probleme das ist allen
gut bekannt das muss man schnell lösen
ich weiß dass man hier Maßnahmen
ergreift aber dennoch muss man daran
denken und dieses System modern aufbauen
zunächst einmal muss man das System der
militärkommissariate modernisieren das
betrifft die die Digitalisierung der
Datenbanken man muss Zusammenarbeit mit
den regionalen Regierungen die das
System der Organisation der Verteidigung
muss gestärkt werden auch in
Zusammenarbeit mit der Industrie
insbesondere muss man das System und die
Aufbewahrung der Militärtechnik des
Materials verbessern für Truppen auch
für die Teil mobil machen bei den
Truppen gibt es jetzt 300.000 neue
Menschen teile von ihnen sind schon auf
den kampffeldern wie mir der
Verteidigungsminister berichtet 150.000
Menschen werden gerade vorbereitet und
das ist eine ausreichende Reserve für
die Operation das ist eine strategische
Reserve die heute nicht bei den
Kampfhandlungen genutzt wird aber diese
Reserve wird vorbereitet werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich möchte
Ihnen aufrichtig Danke sagen auch
unseren Bürgerinnen und Bürger die uns
helfen sie schicken Autos an die
Frontlinie zusätzliche Technik
Ausrichtung warme Kleidung sie schicken
Briefe und Geschenke an verwundete in
Krankenhäusern selbst wenn das
Verteidigungsministerium natürlich für
das Nötigste sorgt muss man dennoch den
Menschen ein großes Dankeschön sagen und
uns verbeugen ich bitte das
Verteidigungsministerium ganz aufmerksam
diese zivilen Initiativen zu verfolgen
sie müssen auch die Kritik ernst nehmen
und rechtzeitig darauf reagieren es ist
klar dass die Reaktion der Menschen die
Probleme sehen
bei so einer großen Aufgabe natürlich
immer auftauchen so eine Reaktion kann
auch emotionaler Natur sein aber man
muss hier natürlich diejenigen erhören
die die existierenden Probleme nicht
totschweigen sondern ihren Beitrag
leisten um sie zu lösen ich bin mir
sicher dass das Verteidigungsministerium
weiter im Kontakt mit den Menschen
stehen wird wir wissen die Armee und das
Volk ist immer unsere Kraft gewesen so
ist es auch heute nun hören wir den
Verteidigungsminister
[Applaus]
heutzutage
stehen den russischen Streitkräften in
der Ukraine die
Drogen die auf die Unterstützung des
ganzen was haben sie bekommen
ukrainische Truppen bekommen
Berater und die ukrainische Führung
nicht vor den
Terroranschlägen und mordschlägen
die westlichen Länder mögen das alles
wollen das alles übersehen zum Beispiel
die Provokationen gegen Atomkraftwerk
saporisha und die Vorbereitung der
sogenannten schmutzigen Bombe
die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika für
sucht dieser Situation zur Schwächung
ihrer Gegner zu auszunutzen wie
besonders
besorgniserregend sind die westlichen
Truppen in der Nähe der
Grenzen Belarus und Russland
nach den
Reden von Frau Merkel und poroschenko
ist das für alle ersichtlich dass nicht
Russland die Quelle des Konflikts des
war sondern
der Stadt Streich in der Ukraine 2014
die ja von den westlichen Ländern
finanziert worden war das hat die
Auseinandersetzungen in dornbuz
ausgelöst und wir leisten jetzt die
Hilfe und wir greifen Maßnahmen zur für
ihre Rettung der Zivil Beförderung wir
vernichten weiterhin die militäre und
wir äh Zielen ab auf die Betriebe die
haben dort die komplexes und die
strategische Objekte darunter auch die
Objekte die Energetik wir wollen die
lieferungs für das Kriegsmaterial
zerstören und dabei
greifen wir alle Maßnahmen zur allen
Maßnahmen um die Opfer der
Zivilbevölkerung zu minimieren
um die verlustedi Ukraine nachzuholen
hat haben die Vereinigten Staaten und
die anderen Länder ihre Lieferungen
aufgestockt 7 und 90 Milliarden Dollar
haben die westlichen Ländern für die
waffenländer Lieferungen in die Türkei
ausgegeben mehr als für die für den
Krieg in Afghanistan zum äh die
gelieferten Waffen
geraten teilweise in die Hände der
Terroristen überall in der Welt
und ähm
in der Zone des Kampfes befinden sich
die
Fachkräfte der westlichen Ländern über
kosmischer Objekte sind im Einsatz im
Interesse der ukrainischen Streitkräfte
sehr viel wird gemacht für die
psychologischen Einfluss auf die
russischen Streitkräfte
es werden in den westlichen Medien
tausende von Fake News veröffentlich
veröffentlicht tausende von
Medien
werden dabei
verwendet und
die
militärverbrechen die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte werden verschwiegen
parallel dazu
wird die ukrainische Armee glorifiziert
alle Handlungen die er ukrainischen
Streitkräfte werden als Heldentaten
dargestellt
wir bekommen jeden Tag viele
Informationen über die Erschießungen der
ukrainischen Soldaten
und
die neuen Aufgaben in die Operation
macht macht notwendig die
mobilenmachung die durchgeführte mobil
machen war eine Herausforderung für das
Land und die
Gesellschaft seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
hatten wir
das nicht machen
müssen und mit der Anfang der Takt mit
der zeitweisen mobil machen hatten wir
mit bestimmten Problemen
konfrontiert kurzfristig müssen wir
erforderliche Maßnahmen ergreifen um die
Situation unter Kontrolle zu behalten
wir müssen alle Arten der Versorgung
optimieren und jetzt können wir
feststellen dass die teilweise mobil
machen erfolgreich durchgeführt worden
ist
300.000 Menschen sind einberufen
sehr gut zusammengearbeitet haben die
zentrale und die regionale machtorgan
Macht Organe ich möchte auch die
[Musik]
positive Einstellung der russischen
Bürger betonen
etwa
830.000
Wehrpflichtigen sind von dem Dienst
freigestellt für die Arbeit in der wir
Industrie und den systemrelevanten
betrieben
danke den Beschlüssen des
Oberkommandierenden bekommen
die
Zeitsoldaten dieser
[Musik]
wie die einberufene Soldaten
vor sehr großen Aufgaben stehen die
viele
Behörden und
Kommando Stellen der
russischen Streitkräften
in diesem Sinne muss noch viel gemacht
werden um
die vor uns stehenden Aufgaben meistern
zu können
im Großen und Ganzen hat die mobil
machen unseres Potenzial verstärkt wir
haben neue Gebiete befreit
Ende Mai haben die russischen
Truppen eine große Großstadt mariopal
von den Nazis befreit die Stadt wurde
von Ukraine zu einem Bollwerk gemacht
insbesondere das trifft für die
Industrieanlage Stahlwerk also
im Laufe der Operation um mariopole
haben die russische Armee und die
Truppen von Don Bass über
4000 Narzissten
vernichtet
sehr viele
ukrainische militären gehören Angehörige
haben sichergeben
jetzt können auch
die russische Streitkräfte die
Hafenanlagen von mir
ausnutzen wir haben die
[Musik]
landesverbindung
zwischen Russland und Kriegen wieder
hergestellt
Eisenbahnlinien werden ausgebaut
werden wir Eisenbahn nach Marie und ja
Jahre später geliefert
wir haben die Wasserlieferungen von
Cream aus dem Nepal wieder hergestellt
nach den langen Jahren der
wasserblockade die Ukraine
Soldaten zeigen sie jetzt tapfer und
selbstlos in dieser Operation über
100.000 Soldaten sind ausgezeichnet
viele davon mit dem ehrentitelheld der
Ukraine
über
250.000 Soldaten haben Erfahrungen
gesammelt während der Operation viele
Menschen sind im Einsatz auf den
befreienden Gebieten bei Entminung zum
Beispiel
die russischen Streitkräfte haben
inzwischen 12
Wohnblocks aufgebaut und sind jetzt bei
dem Aufbau von neuen Kindergärten
behilflich
wir
helfen auch bei
der Schaffung von neuen Krankenhäusern
wir geben uns viel Mühe um die
Wasserversorgung von Donalds
wiederherzustellen wir legen neue
Wasserleitungen
und
arbeiten nach der Wasserleitung vom
flussdorn nach Donezk da sollte die
Wasserversorgung der Stadt Donalds
sicherstellen
unsere Waffensysteme haben ihre
zuverlässigkeit und
Effektivität und der Beweis bestellt und
die sonderoperation bietet einmalige
Möglichkeiten um
die
Methoden der Operation zu prüfen und zu
studieren mit dem Blick auf die
Optimierung der
Streitkräfte und ihren Handlungen
unsere
unsere Ziele Mitbürger
unterstützen die Streitkräfte vollkommen
in diesem Jahr hat das
Verteidigungsministerium auch eine Reihe
von anderen Aufgaben zu lösen seit
Jahresanfang muss haben wir
einen stabilisierenden Einsatz in
Kasachstan durchgeführt mit unseren
Verbündeten und
unsere
Gruppierung ist
Garant des Friedens in
Syrien und in Berg
und unsere
ermöglicht
uns die
Sicherheit
die Sicherheit zu gewährleisten
[Musik]
unsere atomkräfte
führt jetzt die Umrüstung von zwei
regimenten aus wir bekommen neue
kernraketen und die nehmen es in den
Dienst zum Beispiel die Raketen von
neuen Typ Avantgarde
und
darunter auch die schwere Ketten von Typ
sarmat
jetzt sind wir dabei die Raketen zu
Rabatt in den Dienst zu stellen außerdem
bekommen wir neue
Flugzeuges
wir haben in diesem Jahr zwei
Patronen durchgeführt darunter auch in
Kooperation mit unseren chinesischen
Partnern
die russische Marine
einen
weiteren neuen
raketenkreuzer in Dienst genommen mit
den Raketen Boulevard
auch die Streitkräfte werden weiterhin
modernisiert
in den kosmischen kosmischen Kräften wir
neue Leitungssysteme in den Dienst
genommen und jetzt können wir die
Raketen gefährliche Regionen in der
nordlichen Hemisphäre laufend unter
Kontrolle zu halten
in diesem Jahr
es sind die ersten
Pilotinnen
ausgebildet aus dem haben wir in diesem
Jahr die moderne dass moderne
atomares U-Boot indienst genommen und
der ganze Reihe von Schiffen
zerkorn die nur die Raketen von neuem
Typ werden jetzt auch verstärkt in
Dienst genommen
die anerkreuzer horschkopf wird auch mit
diesen Raketen ausgerüstet
die wichtigste
das Wichtigste das wichtigste Aufgabe
für unsere
Rüstungsindustrie war die Belieferung
der Truppen
in der Zone der
sonderoperation und
große Aufgaben warten auf uns im
nächsten im nächsten Jahr wir haben
einen entsprechenden Plan ausgearbeitet
und hier kontrollieren die Erfüllung des
Plans zusammen mit anderen Behörden
die finanziellen Mittel
im laufenden Jahr
aha und erlaubt die Waffenlieferungen in
die Armee auf dem Kampffeld aufzubauen
zugleich die
Erfüllung der Aufgaben der
lieferungsplan beläuft sich auf über 90%
wir haben im laufenden Jahr auch 14
internationale Manöver und Übungen
durchgeführt
im Laufe dieser Manöver haben wir
viele Situationen durchgearbeitet
Höhepunkt war die Manöver was
daran haben sich tausende von Militär
Angehörigen teilgenommen aus 14 Ländern
und
wir haben auch die internationale
Gruppierung geschaffen für die Lösung
der gemeinsamen Aufgaben
zum Beispiel auf dem Gebiet der
regionalen Sicherheit die strategischen
Kern
atomkräfte haben auch die Manöver
durchgeführt
zum Beispiel mit dem Rückschlag mit dem
atomaren Rückschlag auf die
Attacke des Feindes
unsere Streitkräfte haben auch die
Manöver im hohen Norden durchgeführt auf
der Halbinsel zu Podcast und
alle
die ganze Technik hat ihre Möglichkeiten
und der Beweis gestellt und wir sind
dabei
unsere Zusammenarbeit mit anderen
Ländern auszubauen wir halt wir sind im
Kontakt mit über 90
Länder der Welt und wir haben im
laufenden Jahr viele wichtige treffen
durchgeführt und
auch gemeinsame Maßnahmen durchgeführt
wir haben an den internationalen Manöver
total genommen
in den
letzten acht Jahren haben wir im Rahmen
der internationalen Zusammenarbeit viele
Übungsplätze in Russland modifiziert für
die Durchführung der internationalen
Manöver
viele
internationale Maßnahmen sind auch in
diesem Jahr durchgeführt wie das
internationale
Forum für militärische zu Samen Arbeit
viele Verträge sind im Rahmen dieses
Treffens geschlossen
und
wie dieser dieser Treffen über treffen
die
solche ja Märkte
in der Welt
in diesem Jahr haben wir den ersten
internationalen antifastisch
faschistischen Kongress durchgeführt und
der Beteiligung der Vertreter der
zivilengesellschaft der international
der ausländischen der
vielen Länder der Welt
die Teilnehmer haben die
bei mir geht
meine haben den Faschismus und
Narzissmus in der Welt auf das Schärfste
verurteilt und unsere
Lehranstalten sind die Besten der Welt
bei uns lernen die die Jünger für Tiere
aus über 50 Länder der Welt mehr als in
den Lehranstalten die reserviert Union
und in diesem Jahr ist auch eine
entsprechende Offizierschule in Donezk
eröffnet
auch nächstes Jahr werden wir einen
neuen Lehranstalt eröffnen wir in Ohr
ihr Kurzke
wir werden auch unsere
Arbeit mit den Kriegsveteranen vertiefen
und
ausbauen um die Interessen dieser
Bevölkerung Gruppe weiterhin in Schutz
nehmen zu können
49.000 Familien der Militär Angehörigen
haben in diesem Jahr die Wohnungen
eingewiesen bekommen
auch
die
medizinische Seite des Lebens der
Streitkräfte wird immer integriert
wir bauen den Netz der medizinischen
Einrichtungen für die Militär
Angehörigen aus
und wir können immer mehr
Dienstleistungen auf diesem Gebieter zu
leisten
an
unserer Streitkräfte konnten die
medizinische Hilfe an 100.000 Militär
Angehörigen zu leisten und jetzt
können wir gewährleisten dass die erste
medizinische hilft Hilfe am Kampf fällt
innerhalb von erster Stunde geleistet
geleistet wird und die Einlieferung ins
laferl Lazarett erfolgt innerhalb von
einem Tage
Immobilie und
jetzt sind wir bei der Umsetzung des
neuen Programms
für die für die nächste Zeitspanne auf
dem gebüschertier Medizin wir bauen
momentan neu nur 9 neue medizinische
Spital in verschiedene Regionen Regionen
des Landes
wir kennen wir bauen und bauen aus die
genesungszentren in vielen Regionen und
auch im fernen Osten des Landes
was unsere Pläne auf dem gebietschert
ihr Bauarbeiten
angeht so haben wir alle Objekte
erfolgreich fertig gebaut
wir haben in dem letzten Jahr an 600
Objekte gebaut für neue was sind Systeme
und für neuer Raketen
in den
Stützpunkten der russischen Maria Marine
haben wir auch ganze Reihe von Objekten
und
Hafenanlagen fertig gebaut
außerdem haben wir die Infrastruktur die
haben militärischen Objekte und der
Luftwaffe modernisiert
und
wir haben auch über
über
Bauobjekte für zivilenbedarf der
Streitkräfte aufgebaut wir
bauen weiterhin den Eisenbahnnetz
entfernen oft Osten des Landes und in
der Region bei Karl
und da haben wir schon unsere plane auch
erfolgreich erfüllt
auf dem Gebiet der Kulturmaßnahmen haben
wir auch eine Reihe von wichtigen
Paraden durchgeführt
wir haben auch das
memorialer Komplex savour mahieler
rekonstruiert und wieder hergestellt wir
arbeiten weiterhin mit unsere Jugend und
zwar mit der sogenannten jungen Armee
dabei erfassen wir über eine Million
Kinder und Jugendliche und den Ärger
Zusammenarbeit mit den örtlichen
Behörden arbeiten wir an dem Aufbau an
dem Ausbau der
Erziehungsarbeit
in vielen
Städten Russlands wir haben über 150
Schüler in den speziellen
erziehungszentren ausgebildet und dieser
Infrastruktur soll die Grundlage für die
weitere
Beziehungsarbeit darstellen und wir
haben im in diesem Jahr unsere Aufgaben
erzielt erfolgreich erzielt
und unsere Maßnahmen zur Sicherung der
Sicherheit der russischen für der für
Relation
die Maßnahmen zur
zur Verstärkung der NATO
müssen wir unsere Truppen im Norden
immer nur im Nordosten des Landes zu
stärken und
wir müssen
wir müssen einberufungsalter bis 30
Jahre aufzustocken wir müssen für die
Bürger die
Möglichkeiten schaffen einberufen werden
oder direkt einen Vertrag zu schließen
und als Zeitsoldaten zu dienen
wir müssen
unsere Streitkräfte weiterhin und ihre
Struktur weiterhin optimieren
und
wir müssen weiterhin drei neue
motorisierte Divisionen
zu formieren auf dem Gebiet Person und
auch ein Chor in Karelien
wir müssen
auch neuer Verbände
in Westen scharfen das gilt auch für die
landesstreitkräfte wir müssen zwei
luftlande Divisionen aufbauen
das
die Luftwaffen sollen auch weiter
ausgebaut werden
von Formationen
was die
Luftwaffe angeht
wir müssen fünf Artillerie Divisionen
aufstellen und neue Artillerie Brigade
der großen Kapazitäten schaffen
wir müssen auch fünf neue Marine die
Visionen schaffen um
wir müssen die Streitkräfte
[Musik]
auf
eineinhalb Millionen Soldaten aufstocken
in den letzten Jahren sind die
Kapazitäten für Reparatur der
Streitkräfte praktisch
ausgelöscht worden und jetzt sind wir
dabei diese Einheiten wieder aufzubauen
wir müssen eigene Kapazitäten zur
Reparatur der Technik zur Verfügung
haben nächstes Jahr sollen drei Werke
reparaturwerke aufgebaut werden
wir müssen den
Zivildienst auch ausbauen und unsere
militärkommissare arte auch optimieren
die Pläne auf diesem Gebieten werden
auch ob die weiterhin optimiert
im nächstes Jahr werden wir unsere
sonderoperation bis zur Erfüllung der
Aufgaben fortsetzen
unsere Streitkräfte sollen auch den
Frieden in Bergkarabach und in Syrien
gewährleisten
wir müssen uns unsere Streitkräfte
weiterhin ausbauen mit Hinblick auf die
Verstärkung der NATO
wir müssen auch in den
in den Raketen Truppen weitere 22
raketenanlagen mit den Raketen von Typ
Avantgarde und Sam Martin Dienst zu
nehmen
wir müssen nächstes Jahr 300
Raketen
Systeme der Marine in Dienst zu nehmen
das betrifft die U-Boote sowie auch die
weitere
fregatha und Kräuter wir müssen auch an
den weiteren Raketentypen arbeiten
[Musik]
wir den Kurs auf die weitere Entwicklung
der Streitkräfte vorgesetzt
in Details werden die
Ergebnisse der Tätigkeit während der
Sitzung des Kollegiums erörtert vielen
Dank
Vortrag ist beendet
[Applaus]
ja das waren schon mal die Rede des
Präsidenten von Russland Putin und auch
von seinem Verteidigungsminister
schon gut und wir hören jetzt noch mal
was Brötchen zu sagen hat
das ist für alle interessant ist und
natürlich für die heutige Situation
insbesondere ich sagte schon mehrmals
und schrieb auch in meinen Artikeln
unsere strategischen
Gegner
haben ja ein Ziel und zwar
unser Land zu desintegrieren im Laufe
von Jahrhunderten das ist überhaupt
nichts Neues
zu groß denken sie ist das Land das ist
vielleicht eine Bedrohung für
irgendjemanden deswegen muss man das ein
bisschen
denken Sie daran schon immer war das so
über Jahrhunderte üben egal wohin man
schaut so ein Ziel hatte man ich werde
die Beispiel jetzt nicht alle anführen
es reicht aus in die Literatur zu
schauen schon immer wurde der Gedanke
die Idee ausgetragen Pläne wurden
geschmiedet Hoffnungen gab es darauf
dass
ist so oder so gelingen würde für sie
das zu tun und wir unsererseits haben
fast immer fast immer eine ganz andere
einen ganz anderen Ansatz eine ganz
andere Haltung gehabt wir wollten immer
ein Teil sein von dieser sogenannten
zivilisierten Welt und nach dem Zerfall
der Sowjetunion
und wir haben das Jahr mit unseren
eigenen Händen zugelassen wir hatten aus
irgendeinem Grund den Eindruck dass wir
nun jede Minute ein Teil dieser
sogenannten zivilisierten Welt werden
würden aber wie sich herausgestellt hat
hat dort niemand auf uns gewartet
ungeachtet unsere Bemühungen und unserer
Versuche und ich meine auch meine Arbeit
ich habe selbst diese versuchen
unternommen unsere versuchen näher zu
kommen und halt werden das Nein
Direktion war nein ganz im Gegenteil
es wurden andere Maßnahmen ergriffen
auch internationale Terroristen im
Kaukasus wurden eingesetzt um Russland
den letzten Schlag zu versetzen und
unsere Russische Föderation zu
zersplittern viele von den hier
Anwesenden in diesem Saal ich muss Ihnen
nichts beweisen sie wissen ja alle was
passiert ist in den 90ern Anfang der
2000er
das Schiene das al-Qaida verurteilt
wurde und auch andere Verbrecher aber
auf dem Gebiet der Russischen Föderation
das zu nutzen das schien annehmbar sie
wurden unterstützt auch materiell
informationell politisch auch eben
militärisch nur damit sie gegen Russland
kämpfen
danke den Völkern im Kaukasus danke
Tschetschenien und dank unseres
Heldentums konnten wir diese Etappe nun
abschließen wir haben diese
Bewährungsprobe bestanden wir sind
stärker geworden
im weiteren Verlauf sind wir nur noch
besser geworden je weiter desto besser
unsere geopolitischen Gegner und
Wettbewerber haben alles genutzt ich
möchte hier niemanden beleidigen aber
ich möchte es trotzdem sagen sie nutzen
alles was quasi nicht gut verwahrt wurde
für ihre Ziele sie betreiben
Gehirnwäsche in den Ländern auf dem Post
sowjetischen Raum zunächst einmal in der
Ukraine
sie haben das Recht erfolgreich gemacht
sie waren gut vorbereitet darauf denn
schon zu so wird Zeiten gab es ja ganze
Institute die sich darauf spezialisiert
hatten
nach dem staatlichen Umsturz 2014 in der
Ukraine haben wir im Laufe von
Jahrzehnten und das unterstreiche ich
wir haben über Jahrzehnte über Dekaden
haben wir Versuche unternommen
Beziehungen aufzubauen in neuen
geopolitischen Bedingungen aber es wurde
alles gemacht damit in diesen neuen
Bedingungen nicht einfach nur gute
nachbarschaftliche
oder brüderschaftliche Beziehungen
aufzubauen die haben Kredite gegeben
fast schon kostenlose Energie Ressourcen
geliefert über Jahre hinweg nein nein
nichts hat funktioniert einfach gar
nichts ich rufe Ihnen in Erinnerung das
zu Zeiten der das Integration der
Sowjetunion als die Ukraine die Union
verlassen hat sie haben ja in ihrer
Unabhängigkeit Erklärung ich denke mal
die Führungskräfte Russlands haben das
ja auch vorgesehen wir haben
festgeschrieben dass die Ukraine ein
neutraler Staat sein sollte
und deswegen kann man ja die damalige
Führung verstehen insgesamt und wenn man
die Bedingungen derzeit beachtet so
wurden keine Bedrohungen gesehen das ist
doch eine Kultur ein Völker ein Bruder
voll
gemeinsame Geschichte gemeinsame Werte
wir haben überhaupt keine Bedrohungen
gesehen aber nein der Gegner arbeitete
sehr
beharrlich und man muss ja auch zugeben
sehr effizient keine unserer Maßnahmen
zum Aufbau dieser Beziehungen auf die
wir gehofft haben
wurden und waren nicht erfolgreich sie
waren nicht effizient und sie erreichten
auch nicht die gesteckten Ziele
ich möchte das Unterstreichen also es
gibt ja nichts was man uns vorwerfen
könnte ich sage das mit Verantwortung
schon immer und sie kennen ja meine
Position wir haben immer gesagt dass die
Ukraine eine Bruder Volk ist und wir
denken jetzt noch so das was passiert
ist eine gemeinsame Tragödie für uns
aber das ist nicht das Ergebnis unserer
Politik ganz im Gegenteil
das ist das Ergebnis der Politik anderer
Länder Drittländer die schon immer das
angestrebt haben eine disintegration der
russischen Welt
sie haben teilweise Erfolge erzielt und
haben uns nun in eine Lage gebracht in
der wir nun mal sind und nach dem
Staatsstreich 2014 werde ich jetzt nicht
über die Gründe dieses Putsches reden
ich sage nur das war
unzulässig ich erinnere Sie daran dass
2014 im Februar drei
Außenminister aus europäischen Ländern
Polen Frankreich und Deutschland sie
kamen nach Kiew und unterschrieben
als Garanten es war eine Abklärung eine
Vereinbarung zwischen der Regierung der
Opposition ein paar Tage später hatten
wir den Staatsstreich alle vergessen
diese Garantien als ob es sie niemals
gegeben hätte was musste man denn tun
man hätte einfach nur sagen müssen liebe
Freunde wir sind gerannten wir sind die
größten europäischen Länder
wir bitten Sie zurück an den
Verhandlungstisch zurückzukehren wählen
zu gehen und dann mit Hilfe der
politischen Instrumente diese Probleme
zu lösen das war's alle wussten doch
ganz genau
ob das jetzt gut ist oder schlecht ist
aber die Regierung damals sie hätte doch
jede Wahl verloren
denn der Präsident damals stimmte ja zu
der wollte alle Forderungen der
Opposition erfüllen er wollte auch
vorgezogene Wahlen durchführen und wenn
ich meine Kollegen Frage warum habt ihr
es zu einem Staatsstreich kommen lassen
naja sie wissen ja es gibt keine Antwort
zucken einfach mit den Schultern naja es
war halt so
das heißt man gab uns zu verstehen dass
keine russischen Kräfte und jegliche
politischen Tätigkeiten Journalisten
die ihre Stimme erheben wollten
zugunsten der Beziehungen mit Russland
sie wurden einfach auf offener Straße
getötet und niemand hat irgendetwas
ermittelt es wurde klar dass es
überhaupt keine Chance gibt überhaupt
gar keine Chance nicht den Hauch einer
Chance die Beziehungen mit diesem Teil
wiederherzustellen
unseres ehemals gemeinsam Landes das ist
einfach unmöglich
im Grunde
ist es doch eine terrorpraxis das wurde
genutzt
absolut frech und dreist
es fand einige Hirnwäsche der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger in der Ukraine
statt es wurden
neonazistische Ideologie eingesetzt über
Jahrzehnte und das zeigte nun mal
Ergebnisse was ist das aber schauen Sie
mal
emotionale Helden
das bemerkte niemand ja sie sind
Nationalisten ja in jedem Land gibt es
Nationalisten auch bei uns
aber die Phänomene des Faschismus des
neonationalismus bekämpfen wir doch das
ist doch nicht Teil unserer nationalen
Politik aber in Ukraine schon und alle
tun so als würden sie das nicht bemerken
der Nationalismus ist ja vielleicht gar
nicht so schlecht sie verteidigen ja
nationale Interessen aber das geschieht
ja auf der Grundlage von faschistischen
Neo narzisstischen Ideologien das
bemerkt niemand sie laufen mit
Hakenkreuzen in Zentren von großen
Städten darunter auch in der Hauptstadt
herum und Gott sei Dank ja so gehört
sich das auch warum nicht warum denn wie
in den 90ern und Anfang der 2000er
gab es ja internationale Terroristen die
eingesetzt wurden im Kampf gegen
Russland es war doch egal das ist
Terroristen waren sie waren anerkannte
internationale Terroristen aber es war
ihnen egal sie wurden einfach eingesetzt
im Kampf gegen Russland und die
neonazisten werden hier auch eingesetzt
im Kampf gegen Russland es ist egal dass
sie Neonazis sind hauptsache sie kämpfen
gegen Russland aber uns ist es nicht
egal
es ist nun offensichtlich es war damals
schon damals dass die Konfrontation mit
diesen Kräften auch in der Ukraine
unumgänglich ist die Frage ist nur wann
das geschehen würde
natürlich
natürlich sind die militärischen
Kampfhandlungen natürlich sind Sie immer
eine Tragödie natürlich werden Menschen
ihre leben lassen das wissen wir doch
und wir verstehen das aber es ist
unumgänglich und es ist besser dass
heute zu tun als morgen und ich denke
alle hier in diesem Saal Anwesenden
sehr gut verstehen was ich sage ich
meine auch den Zustand unserer
Streitkräfte und die
Anwesenheit von perspektivischen Waffen
Technik Ausrüstung andere Länder haben
das nicht wir haben das schon das alles
schafft Reserve und Resilienz was wir
haben wir können unsere Vorteile wir
haben Atomwaffen kosmische
Möglichkeiten Flotte und so weiter wir
kennen das alles sehr gut wir haben das
alles
im richtigen notwendigen Zustand wir
sehen auch auch das was wir tun müssen
für die Optimierung und Perfektionierung
der Streitkräfte in der Infanterie bei
der Kommunikation und so weiter und so
fort alle die hier anwesend sind wissen
was ich meine und ich bin mir sicher sie
stimmen mit mir überein aber was ich
hier noch einmal hervorheben möchte
in Russland
es gibt nicht viele solcher Länder und
ich rede überhaupt nicht mehr über
unsere Nachbarn sie haben bald gar
nichts mehr
sie bekommen einfach nur Geschenke
von anderen Ländern in Russland ist es
ganz anders wir haben alles und ich
unterstreiche das wir haben alle
Möglichkeiten um dieses Potenzial zu
erhöhen das werden wir zweifelsfrei auch
tun ohne irgendwelche Rabatte und
Zugeständnisse und im Gegensatz zu
anderen Ländern wie ich sagte haben wir
unsere eigenen wissenschaftlichen
technischen
produktionellen und personellen
Grundlage all das werden wir nutzen um
uns weiter zu entwickeln
wir werden diese Aufgaben lösen ohne
Schaden für die Wirtschaft oder den
sozialen Bereich ohne
ohne dass wir irgendwelche Pflichten
gegenüber unseren Menschen und Bürger
nicht erfüllen auch im sozialen Bereich
alle gesteckten Pläne und Ziele
alle unseren
perspektivischen Aufgaben werden erfüllt
und gelöst wir werden nicht die Fehler
der Vergangenheit wiederholen als wir im
Interesse der höheren
Verteidigungsbereitschaft wo es
notwendig waren wo es auch nicht
notwendig war wir unsere Wirtschaft
zerstört haben wir werden keine
Militarisierung des Landes vorantreiben
und auch nicht die Wirtschaft
militarisieren einfach nur weil wir nun
stand heute einen Entwicklungsstand
haben in den Strukturen der Wirtschaft
wir brauchen das einfach nicht zu tun
das ist nicht notwendig wir müssen nicht
zu viel machen
was dann dem Land und unseren Menschen
unserer wirtschaftsschaden würde auch im
sozialen Bereich das möchte ich noch
einmal hervorheben wir haben das nicht
vor wir werden das nicht tun wir werden
die Streitkräfte und die
militärkomponente perfektionieren aber
in Ruhe rhythmisch ohne hasst und
konsequent kontinuierlich wir werden die
militärische Verteidigungsbereitschaft
stärken und die Aufgaben lösen
die wir uns gesteckt haben im Laufe der
militärischen sonderoperation ich stimme
zu was Sie gesagt haben zu ihren
Vorschlägen bei den strukturellen
Veränderungen nach den Besprechungen des
Kollegiums bitte ich Sie hier Bericht
zur erstatten dann werden wir das
ausführlich besprechen ich möchte mich
bei Ihnen allen bedanken für alles was
sie getan haben und ich bin mir sicher
und ich möchte Ihnen sagen aber das
wissen Sie ja auch wie die Lage im Land
ist das ganze Land schaut auf die
Streitkräfte und wünscht Ihnen viel
Erfolg alles Gute und wir zweifeln gar
nicht dass alle Ergebnisse erreicht
werden die wir definiert haben die sie
selbst ja auch definiert haben sie
erstatten ja Bericht ich zweifle nicht
dass alle Ziele die wir uns gesteckt
haben auf jeden Fall erreicht werden
vielen Dank und alles Gute
[Applaus]
quasi die Übertragung der Rede von
Staatspräsident der Präsident Wladimir
Putin und seinem Verteidigungsminister
schon gut anlässlich der Ziele des für
2023 im militärischen Bereich von
Russland ja und das möchte ich gerne
noch mal ein bisschen analysieren mit
Professor Heinemann Brüder
Politikwissenschaftler und
konfliktforscher ich würde gerne noch
mal auf das Ende auf diesen Nachtrag von
Vladimir Putin den er eben noch mal zum
Besten gegeben hat da würde ich gerne
noch mal mit ihm drauf eingehen was hat
das eigentlich zu bedeuten er ist ja
noch mal auf die Ereignisse 20/14
eingegangen hat das ja quasi als
Staatsstreich bezeichnet die
demokratische Umwälzung in der Ukraine
und hat es auch noch mal als
Rechtfertigung benutzt ist das eher ein
Politiker ein Präsident Russlands in der
Ecke in die Enge getrieben oder einer
der Nachfolger nach vorne schaut
das Erstaunliche ist ja das zwischen den
beiden Reden ein großer Widerspruch
besteht auf der einen Seite hat er erst
gesagt der Krieg hat große
managementprobleme zu Tage gefordert
Logistik Kommunikation
Nachschub Mobilisierung und so weiter
und da hatte man den Eindruck er will
das alles dem Verteidigungsminister ins
Stammbuch schreiben und in der zweiten
Rede hat er noch mal das
begründungsarrativ hervorgerufen und
zwar hatte historisch soweit ausgeholt
als ob es eigentlich immer das Ziel des
Westens gewesen wäre Russland kaputt zu
machen zu zerschlagen und die Einheit
der russischen Welt das heißt also auch
die Zugehörigkeit der Ukraine zu dieser
russischen Welt
zu zerstören das heißt er hat noch mal
einen einen rechtfertigungs narrativ
gegeben im Sinne auch dessen wenn wir
jetzt nicht äh jetzt zugeschlagen hätten
dann wären unsere Chance
geringer gewesen also besser heute als
zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt wo wir
möglicherweise diese Chancen nicht mehr
gehabt hätten und er hat sich noch mal
sehr geäußert über den Verrat den
vermeintlichen der Ukraine die ja
einerseits Brüder Volk sind andererseits
aber einer Gehirnwäsche ausgesetzt
gewesen sind
die von Westen ausgehen ja und hat sich
auch über faschistische und ja auch
national oder neonazistische Tendenzen
in der Ukraine geäußert aber die
natürlich nie belegt worden sind ich
würde gerne noch mal ein zwei Aspekte
aus diesen beiden reden von Wladimir
Putin den Präsidenten und dem
Verteidigungsminister Scholl guh heraus
aber arbeiten und zwar gibt es ja einmal
dort bei beiden noch mal die Betonung
man wollte sich jetzt anstrengen man
wollte jetzt sozusagen Versäumnisse aus
der Vergangenheit der versuchen jetzt
weg zu machen im militärischen Bereich
man hat ja auch noch mal angesprochen
welche Anstrengung da unternommen werden
sollen schaukuh der verteil
Bundesminister hat noch mal und das hat
ja auch Wladimir Putin noch mal
aufgegriffen auch noch mal die
Atomwaffen besonders betont sind das
tatsächlich jetzt noch mal reale Dinge
die da hervorgehoben worden sind oder
wir waren da kurz vor der Rede im hängen
geblieben sind das diese potenzcam
Dörfer die man jetzt noch mal versucht
hervorzuziehen
also die Botschaft ist die macht euch im
Westen keine Illusionen wir sind hier
nicht durch den ukrainekrieg geschwächt
sondern wir können gleichzeitig noch die
strategische Parität mit den USA
aufrecht erhalten wir sind in der Lage
diese
Intercontinental Raketen auch in Dienst
zu stellen
muss man allerdings sagen dass diese in
Dienststellung der neuen interkantine
Teil Raketen schon seit mindestens zehn
Jahren immer wieder angekündigt wird und
insofern hat das in der Tat so den
Geschmack von portugiesisches Dörfern
weil
sozusagen an den Westen gerichtet ist
ähm
ihr müsst uns noch nicht abschreiben
aber wann denn in der Tat diese Raketen
in Dienst gestellt werden wird offen
gelassen aber es hat so ein bisschen den
Geschmack von brechschnäppchen sag mal
planen über Erfüllungs reden um sich
selber sozusagen gute Stimmung wieder
herzustellen
eine Sache fiel in beiden Reden auf noch
mal wie sehr doch die Bevölkerung hinter
diesem Kriege wo die ja weiter noch von
russischer Seite als militärische
spezialoperation bezeichnet aber dieser
Angriffskrieg wie sehr die Bevölkerung
dahinter stehen würde wie sehr sie das
unterstützen würde was glauben Sie denn
sie sind ja auch konfliktforscher wann
bricht das auf weil man wurde ja auch
jetzt noch mal sehr deutlich sagte man
baut Krankenhäuser beispielsweise für
die Verletzten und verwundeten Soldaten
man versucht dort auch noch das die
Gehälter werden teilweise aufgestockt
aber auf der anderen Seite wurde und das
fand ich sehr bemerkenswerte das
einberufungsalter das ja momentan bei 27
liegt auf 30 Jahre noch mal erhöht also
es wird immer mehr Menschen dort treffen
die irgendwie von diesem Krieg auch
direkt berührt sind glauben sie noch mal
an eine Widerstandsbewegung in Russland
auch nach solchen reden
also die zimmerstimmungsraten zu dem
Krieg sind eingebrochen eindeutig es
gibt vielleicht so einen harten Kern von
15 bis 20 Prozent der Bevölkerung die
diesen Krieg aktiv unterstützen dann
gibt es vielleicht eine entsprechend
große Zahl die
sehr gegen den Krieg eingestellt sind
und die anderen
versuchen ihn möglichst fern zu halten
sich dement zu entziehen der ist aber
insgesamt immer weniger populär man
sieht es auch an der Anzahl derjenigen
die sich dann zu entziehen versuchen die
ins Ausland gehen
es gibt ja schon viele Nachbarstaaten in
denen also dauerhaft jetzt auch die
Linien sind die ja
potenziell einberufen werden es gibt
immer vor allen Dingen im Protest
weniger von den Soldaten Müttern als von
den jungen Ehefrauen von einem
berufenden die dann kleinen Kinder haben
und sich fragen warum soll mein Mann
eigentlich hier an einer Front in der
Ukraine umkommen für unbekannte Ziele
das heißt wenn diejenigen die jetzt
unmittelbare Angehörige sind der
Wehrpflichtigen da ist die Stimmung
meines Erachtens schon sehr gekippt und
das kann auch nicht wettgemacht werden
mit solchen
Auskünften wir bauen ja Kindergarten und
Krankenhäuser und verbessern die
medizinische Versorgung also insofern
die Stimmung ist gekippt allerdings ist
sie nicht mehr organisierbar weil eben
die zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen zerschlagen sind die
Anführer sind im Ausland die Medien sind
im Ausland oder
man ist so hohen Straftaten zu hohen
Strafen verurteilt worden
Jasmin zum Beispiel hier vor zehn Tagen
ein Menschenrechtler zu achteinhalb
Jahren weil er die Kriegsführung einer
Ukraine kritisiert hat also die
Organisationen dieses Unmut ist sehr
schwer geworden
mein Name ist ja auf der Pressekonferenz
überhaupt nicht gefallen wurde glaube
ich wenn ich mich jetzt richtig ins
Sinne gar nicht namentlich erwähnt das
ist der Präsident der Ukraine ist hier
lensky der übrigens momentan gar nicht
in der Ukraine ist der befindet sich ja
auf dem Weg Richtung USA da haben wir ja
jetzt auch noch mal hier ein paar Bilder
das sollen Bilder wohl in bachmut
gestern gewesen sein dort hatte silenski
die Front die stark und kämpfte Stadt
besucht hier und hier geht es hier sehen
wir ein paar Patriot raketener bei denen
wird es auch darum gehen wann die
Ukraine diese Patriot Raketen bekommen
wird also das ist sicherlich auch noch
mal die große Frage was erwarten sie
denn von diesem Besuch von der silenski
in den USA Herr Professor Heinemann
Brüder
ich erwarte dass selenski sehr Druck
darauf ausübt dass die USA sozusagen ihr
langfristig ihre Lieferverpflichtungen
auch auch einlösen das ist auch ein
parteiübergreifenden Konsens weiterhin
im Kongress gibt und dass er sich mit
jedem auseinandersetzt die im Pentagon
vielleicht für die Aufnahme schon von
Waffenstillstands oder
Friedensverhandlungen sind und dass er
mit den Amerikanern die Bedingungen
abstimmt auch in der Kommunikation weil
die Befürchtung ist natürlich dass zum
Beispiel auch macron hier eine eine
zweite verhandlungsfront aufmacht und
man da sicherstellen will dass die
Amerikaner auch für eine gewisse Einheit
der westlichen Haltung Sorge tragen
Einschätzung von Professor Heinemann
Rüdiger Politikwissenschaftler und
konfliktforscher ausbauen herzlichen
Dank für diesen vielfältigen Einblick
auch vor allen Dingen auch noch mal die
Interpretation der reden die wir gerade
eben gehört haben